Attention-Deficit and Hyperactivity Disorder
or ADHD is a diagnosable disorder that has
to do with how some people’s brains function.
But some researchers are saying it might not
be a brain disorder… it might be a sleep
disorder!
We know getting a good night’s sleep is
important — it’s vital for healthy brain
function, your immune system health, and basic
cognitive functionality.
It’s all part of the 24-hour circadian cycle
that determines when our bodies eat and sleep,
and also comes with brainwave activity, hormone
production, cell regeneration, and other biological
processes.
We also know getting bad, insufficient, or
disrupted sleep can cause anxiety, depression,
increased impulsivity, and general cognitive
issues.
Basically, ADHD and bad sleep sure look a
lot alike, according to a growing body of
evidence.
One Dutch researcher believes, based on studies,
that sleep habits and ADHD may be quote “two
sides of the same physiological and mental
coin.”
Which is kind of a revolution in how we think
about ADHD.
Studies have shown over 70 percent of kids
and adults with ADHD have sleep problems,
and they’ve also shown if you fix the sleep
disruption some of the symptoms of ADHD can
disappear!
We’re not saying ADHD isn’t real, it definitely
is.
But instead, science is seeing the beginnings
of a connection between the attention and
hyperactivity in kids, and their sleep -- rather
than just a brain disorder.
Preschoolers and kindergarteners need between
10 and 13 hours of sleep a night, but in many
cases are getting less than 9.
Late-night iPad movies, demands of perfection,
and after-school activities could leave kids
so stimulated they can’t sleep, disrupting
the length, timing and quality of sleep which
may manifest as ADHD.
Disorders like sleep apnea and other nighttime
breathing issues can also cause bad sleep
which might mimic ADHD symptoms!
Obviously, this isn’t the answer to all
cases of ADHD.
There ARE still children — and adults — who
really DO need treatment.
But it could be the case that sometimes what
looks like ADHD might be resolved by simply
sticking to a bedtime routine.
For more Seeker, be sure to subscribe!
And speaking of sleeping, Amy dug into how
white noise might help you get better rest
in this video right here.
And one weird way to get better sleep?
Turn up the AC!
We sleep better when we’re a little cold.